- All right, why are we talking today
about voice?
Voice is actually not yet out of fashion.
Voice still exists
and is very persistent
actually across different
technologies from fixed to
mobile to voice assistance
and actually now in AI-powered
voice communication.
And what we are gonna do now
today is really talk about
how AI-powered voice
communication has benefits
to improve customer
experience, to reduce cost,
and actually increase security
in financial services.
I am here today actually with Chao
and I let you present yourself Chao.
- Sure. So my name is Chao.
I'm a director of applied
science with Amazon.
I've been with Amazon for
about 10 years, initially
working in Alexa on the speech
interactive experiences.
And now I lead a team in
AGI foundations focusing on
building the speech-to-speech
foundation model.
So I hope you've all heard
about the announcement
of Nova Sonic launch this morning
and I'm really excited to
have this opportunity to talk
to you about Sonic a little bit
and also about the
collaboration with Vonage
to use speech foundation models to build
AI agents that can interact
with users as naturally
and intelligently as human agents.
- Thank you. And my name is Christophe.
I'm a president of the
business unit API at Vonage.
And we are a company responsible
for cloud communication,
doing a communication
platform as a service
and also network API, allowing
applications to communicate
with users.
Now, as I said, voice is very persistent
and it has been so over time,
across multiple technologies.
It started all with fixed voice.
You could dial a human connecting
offices, connecting homes,
then it was on the mobile
side, you could actually talk
and communicate on the move.
Then to voice assistance,
actually using your voice
to do a command or ask for the weather
or a certain command and a response.
And then now AI-powered voice,
where actually you can
have a real interaction
with an agent, which is multi-turn
and which also remembers basic
your previous interactions.
And why is voice persistent?
It's because it's fast,
it's faster than dialing;
it's situational, wherever you are;
and it also supports
actually context and nuance
and personalization.
What are the benefits that we are seeing
of AI-powered voice?
When we look at the finance sector,
on one hand there is an
enhanced customer experience.
So personalization actually
of that is possible.
It remembers your past
interactions that you had.
It's 24/7 available.
You can always call an
an AI-powered agent.
Voice agent is always there
and it's emotionally intelligent now.
So basically it can grasp
actually frustration
and can show more empathy
or adapt a bit the pace
and the reaction.
Secondly, it results into efficiency.
Which type of efficiencies?
Well of course you can
automate repetitive tasks
like your balance inquiry.
It's scalable in a sense
that when you have peaks,
for example on the tax returns,
it can absorb that by your agents
and of course cost saving from less agents
in your call center.
But also important for security reasons.
Why for security?
Well, with your voice
footprint is an ability
to be authenticated or of
course when there is fraud,
you can be called by a voice agent
when there is a fraudulent
activity on your account.
And this 24/7.
So there is also a lot of security
and compliance applications
that are applicable
for AI-powered voice.
And also towards the future,
but Chao will get more
into detail on that.
We will see there is an opportunity
for much more proactivity
and also integration with other
type of channels like text
so that you have a unified
customer experience,
not only purely voice.
Now what are actually some of
the use cases that it enables?
When you look at financial services,
actually there is a multitude
of use cases that are possible.
When we look at the banking
and financial services, there is actually
really customer support.
As I said, very basic routine
balance inquiries can be done by agents,
it actually can give
personalized recommendation.
An agent can give you a
recommendation for investments
but also fraud protection as I said,
using actually your voice
footprint for authentication.
It can call you when there
is fraudulent activity
on your account that has been spotted.
And it can also of course
for compliance reasons,
record certain transactions
that you are having
and know actually when to do that.
For wealth and management and investment.
Other use cases are, for
example, proactive recommendation
for fund investments and
many other engagements.
On the insurance side,
we could imagine actually basic claims
entering basic information
around the claim
can be done through AI agents
but also lead qualification.
You can by asking simple
question it could do
a prioritization of leads
or an assessment, a risk assessment
of a potential lead in insurance.
So a lot of use cases that are possible.
But then comes the question
how do we do this technology wise?
And that's why we are gonna
now give both a presentation
on what is Amazon Nova Sonic.
Enabling actually from a speech-to-speech
modeling perspective
and how the combination with
the voice infrastructure
of Vonage can make it easy for developers
and enterprises to build
agents in an easy way.
So Chao, I'll let you...
- Yeah, thank you.
So okay, so
I want to tell you a little
bit more about Nova Sonic.
Nova Sonic is a speech-to-speech
foundation model
for real time human-like
conversational AI.
And maybe I can walk you
through this diagram first
because that will give you an idea of why
a speech-to-speech foundation
model is like the future.
It revolutionizes how we
build these kind of agents.
So the first thing when
you look at this picture is
how simple it is
because if you've worked with voice agents
for a long time then you'll
probably be very familiar
with the traditional cascade
kind of system architecture
where you start with an ASR system
that converts speech into text.
Then you might have like an NRU system
that derives meaning out of that text
and you have some kind of
dialogue control that figures out
how to sort of respond to the customer.
And then you have a TTS system
that turns the response text into speech
with foundation model,
literally you just integrate
with a bi-directional streaming interface
and this interface handles everything.
So you have speech coming in
and then inside this model it's going
to do streaming based processing.
As soon as the speech
is received by the model
and the inference engine,
it's going to actually
generate live transcript
out of the speech and it can also generate
API tool calling kind
of commands if the input
of requires that kind of handling.
And then when the tool call
information comes back,
the model can generate the response,
incorporating the information
coming back from the tool,
coming back from, you know,
the developer's design of
what this agent is supposed to do.
And then at that point of time it's going
to generate agent speech.
And the beauty of this
whole pipeline is that
we actually have the transcript,
which is the text representation
of what the user said
as an intermediate output which
help grounding sort of like
what the agent think the user is saying.
So it brings transparency
about sort of like
the agent's behavior in
terms of how to handle this.
It also is able
to generate the speech taking into account
all the information that's
available to this large model
that includes all the dialogue history
as well as the input user speech
so that the agent's speech
can be not only natural
and expressive but also
it's paying attention to
how the user is expressing
themselves in addition
to the content of what they say.
That way the agent's
behavior will be a lot more
empathetic and human-like.
So I just want to walk
through a little bit of this.
So essentially with this
architecture you can do very
fluid dialogue handling
and natural turn taking.
By that what I mean is as soon as the user
finishes speaking,
the system is going to make
a determination to say,
"Oh the customer finished speaking,"
and it's going to start responding.
But if the customer interrupts
the agent responses,
it's going to stop almost immediately
and to listen to the customer
and then respond to what they said next.
We also are very proud
of our speech recognition performance.
And you probably see in this
morning's keynote presentation
that we achieve state
of the art accuracies
speech recognition.
And I mentioned that we support
adaptive speech responses,
adaptive meaning it's adapting
to how user is speaking,
not only just what they're speaking.
And I mentioned that if we
have very expressive voices,
I hope you'll show a demo
that demonstrates that
and it's available in multiple languages.
And because of this
very simple architecture
of speech-to-speech, it naturally achieves
very low latency in responding.
All right.
- And actually what we
are doing is combining
the Amazon Nova Sonic technology
with the Vonage Voice API.
So basically combining the
Amazon Nova Sonic AI capabilities
and speech-to-speech models
with the voice infrastructure of Vonage.
So actually that it is very
easy to do inbound calls,
outbound calling, it can be
done on multiple technologies.
So it can be done on mobile apps, web apps
or the very traditional PSTN calls.
So it's really the combination of the two,
the voice infrastructure
together with Nova Sonic.
That makes it actually
easy for enterprises,
for developers to build agents
and that's what we really try
to do by that partnership.
But that combination is to
make it easy for developers
to build agents for the future.
But of course we want to demo this.
This is always better
than explaining slides
and how it could work.
So let's have a little sneak
peek on how that can work.
(animation chiming)
- [Agent] Hello, this is your
financial services assistant.
For your security, please say the phrase,
"My voice confirms my identity."
- My voice confirms my identity.
- [Agent] Authentication
is complete and secure.
Hello, how can I assist you today?
- What is my current
savings account balance?
- [Agent] Let me retrieve
your current savings
account balance for you.
Your savings balance is $23,540.15.
Let's switch to your investments.
Your portfolio is doing
quite well this year
with a total value of $512,040.75,
which is up by 6.2% year to date.
- Okay, let's schedule a call
with my financial advisor.
Can you help me with that?
- [Agent] Certainly I can
help you schedule a call
with your financial advisor.
Let me check the
availability for next week.
It looks like your advisor
is available on Tuesday
at 10:00 AM.
Would that work for you?
- Do you have any openings for Wednesday?
- [Agent] Let me check the
availability for Wednesday.
It appears that your advisor
is available on Wednesday
at 2:00 PM.
Would that time work for you?
- That works.
- [Agent] Great, I've scheduled a meeting
with your financial advisor
for Wednesday at 2:00 PM.
You will receive a
confirmation email shortly.
- Alright, so that's how it works.
Cool, huh?
So now of course we explained a bit
what we have now, but maybe you can,
without divulging any secrets,
tell us a bit what is next?
What is our...
- Yeah, yeah.
Well actually it's easy for me
because we just announced
Sonic, Nova 2 Sonic,
which is the next generation of Sonic.
And let me just give you a sneak peek
of the new features that we launched.
So Sonic, in version one
supports English, French,
Italian, German, and Spanish.
And with Sonic 2 we added new languages,
Hindi and Portuguese.
And we have an exciting
language roadmap in the pipeline
that hopefully we will
share in coming quarters.
We also added what we
call polyglot voices,
which means the voice can
speak multiple languages
even though the original voice
talent were only monolingual.
And this way we can handle sessions
with language switching very seamlessly.
A user can literally
switch between, you know,
let's say English and Spanish,
depending on how they feel
comfortable almost naturally
expressing themselves.
And the same agent voice can respond
in English or Spanish given that context.
We also added a feature called
asynchronous tool calling.
'Cause you know these models,
they're very fast if you're
just doing chitchatting,
but if sometimes you go
off to do a tool call,
that can take a long time.
And if you're just waiting
for the tool call to come back
to continue the conversation,
then you sometimes get stuck
in this very awkward silence
with the user and
sometimes the user would be
wondering like, what's going on
'cause the system almost feels like
it's kind of dead or broken.
So we enabled this asynchronous
tool calling capability
where the agent can basically
continue the conversation
with the customer when
the tool call is being
executed in the background.
And when the tool call in, you
know, the results comes back,
the agent is going to incorporate
that information into the
dialogue to continue sort of
the conversation with the
customer in a very natural way.
Another feature we added is actually
to add text into the speech input as well.
So it's not just speech-to-speech,
it's actually speech
and text to speech and text.
That way, even though we say
that these are voice
first kind of experiences,
having text capabilities is
helpful for a lot of use cases.
For example, if you want
the agent to say something
before the customer say anything,
then you can use the text
input from the developer side
to prompt the model so that the model
will start speaking without waiting
for the user to have speech input.
You can also use that capability
to handle like touch pad kind of inputs
so that these touch pads key presses
can be converted into text
as input into the model.
The benefit of this is all
of these are seamlessly
incorporated into the model
as if it's like just a same...
Like there's never loss of
context or switch of context
when you have different modality of input.
It's all the same context information
available to the model.
One last feature that I want
to talk to you about is the...
Oh, configurable turn taking behavior.
So we all like these
agents to be like snappy,
you talk and then the agents comes back.
But there are actually scenarios
where users prefer the agents
to be a little bit more relaxed
so they don't feel like they
have to talk in case they stop,
then the agent will cut them off.
So there is ability to configure
these kind of thresholds
to be sensitivity low, medium, high,
so that you can basically
trade off sort of
some of these latencies for just a more
relaxed kind of interaction vibe.
So I think that's what I can share now.
Hopefully, you know, if you
watch for our Nova pages
then you'll see we always
update and launch new features
over the course of the year.
- Yeah, and if you wanna learn more...
- Oh that's right.
So I should mention this.
So there are quite a few
sessions to talk about Sonic,
if you want to learn
how to build with Sonic.
There's a workshop, which is amazing.
It's two hours long
and it tells you everything about how
to build these kind of agents.
Unfortunately it's happening
right now, so you are not going
to be able to catch it.
But these sessions are
recorded so you should be able
to look it up, searching for keywords
or the session to watch
it at a later time.
There's these chalk talks
that are happening in
the next couple of days
and also there's a breakout
session which goes into
one hour long presentation about Sonic.
I hope you'll be able to
catch that one tomorrow.
- Yep, and you're always welcome
at the Vonage meeting room
and we have also drinks
and presentation later tonight at Paris.
I think some leaflets will be
handed out right over there
if you're interested
to come and learn more.
So thank you all for your attention.
- Thank you so much for attending.
- Bye-bye.